look they have lied about me from the
beginning they said that i led a
reconnaissance tour january 5th okay i
don't even think i was in the capital
january 5th and
january 2nd i brought my family into the
capitol as a member elect with a capitol
hill police officer i have my four boys
my son my mom
and my husband and my mom so i'm sorry
sometimes he's like my son
and you know and and we're we're looking
at this capital that i i'm about to be
sworn in as a member of congress
how do you guys fight the messaging
though because i covered all the
election laws the georgia stuff the
texas stuff there was nothing racist in
it there was nothing
against causing anyone to vote these
were things to make elections safer an
id you have to show an id when you rent
a golf club mini golf like basic things
but the messaging all is that you guys
are racist and you don't want people to
vote and you're stealing elections like
how do you beat that thing
um if there's anything that's racist
it's vaccine passports um because
there's actually you have to show an
idea right
exactly yes yes you have to show it an
id to to get a vaccine and then even in
places like new york it's it's
more difficult to sit down in a
restaurant and eat than it is to cross
our southern border illegally right um
you know so i mean this is absurd so if
they want to talk about identification
being racist well let's flip it right
back on them and talk about these
vaccine mandates that are coming from
the white house
this is something that is affecting
people's livelihoods i'm so proud of the
nurses that have taken a stand the
southwest pilots that have taken a stand
i know um united had a victory um with a
judge that that put a pause on this
are you telling me that it wasn't just
weather that delayed those southwest i
heard joe biden he said it was just
weather yeah it wasn't just weather
maybe it was hurricane brandon i don't
know it was hurricane brandon it was
definitely that brandon guy yeah but but
but even that the way they blatantly lie
we all see what's happening you can look
at the weather radar yeah
could the weather only affect one
airline is that possible just one yes um
other airlines um had two percent of
their flights that were canceled
it's absolutely absurd but what do you
do with that i mean i keep driving it
home to this point but like that seems
to me the bigger issue just that they
can lie and get away with lies and call
you the liar and me the liar and all of
our audience the liar when they're
always lying but it seems to be working
yes we have to have conversations like
this joe rogan just confronted cnn about
about taking uh so-called horse medicine
horse through warmer he's like no you
said this
your
your uh company who you work for said
this cnn said it and you didn't stop
them you know yeah maybe that was bad no
no no but you didn't stop it and that's
what we have to do we have to continue
to call them out on what they're doing
look they have lied about me from the
beginning they said that i led a
reconnaissance tour january 5th okay i
don't even think i was in the capital
january 5th and
january 2nd i brought my family into the
capitol as a member elect with a capitol
hill police officer i have my four boys
my son my mom and my husband and my mom
so i'm sorry sometimes he's like my son
and you know and and we're we're looking
at this capital that i i'm about to be
sworn in as a member of congress
and
um steve cohen chairman of the bad hair
caucus from tennessee you know he
he sees us in the hall waves at us and
then goes on cnn and says i was leading
a reconnaissance to her like and they
and they are able to lie and get away
with this and this is something my
family has been attacked for received
death threats over
my mom has received
death threats and even filed a lawsuit
against a very notable
influencer
he said that she was the bullhorn lady
on january 6th and the bullhorn lady
there's this woman with a pink hat and
she's got a bullhorn she's yelling and
she's like giving directions for people
we can't even find the bathrooms in the
capitol like we can lead a
reconnaissance tour give give people
directions and so you're right they're
able to lie all the time and they
absolutely get away with it
and we have to be there to expose the
truth i i think everyone
we're created to recognize truth and so
if we keep putting that out there more
people will gravitate to that truth i
you did
i did yeah no i mean yes believe me it's
the only way i could do what i do for a
living if you didn't believe that the
truth matters then i don't know how you
could wake up and fight in congress or
talk about politics for a living you'd
basically go crazy but then the other
piece of that which you sort of
referenced already is the big tech piece
obviously which is now it's not only
that they can lie but their lies get
injected with steroids and our truth
gets actually cut off at the knees
because they won't let certain things
get out now it's even worse can we do
about that miss congressman oh man
well i i need a majority to do something
um because republicans aren't going to
be able to fix this in the minority
there's no democrat that's going to say
yeah republicans need a platform
they they they need to to have this uh
censorship removed so they could have
more likes on on twitter and you know uh
it's so funny we try to get something
trending we have the followers but they
don't see it and then you know just
after seven minutes lauren bobert is so
double trend number one all day long
because it's allowed to yeah because
they let it um
and uh so it's it's okay i have fun with
that stuff too you know i'm not dumb
enough to think that seven trillion
dollars equals zero so try again um wait
a minute so you're saying if you spend
three point five trillion dollars that
doesn't equal zero yeah it doesn't equal
zero it doesn't exist
gosh
yes but that's another one yes there are
anti-trust laws for this reason so these
big companies these big bullies can't
suppress the little guys um like they
did with with parlor you know that was
getting too big for them and
we have to be in the majority to be able
to do something i know jim jordan
is working on legislation and i think
that's where it's going to take place um
i think judiciary is going to get to the
bottom of this and we're going to have
some effective legislation um to to make
sure
section 230 is gone or
or at least um
these companies are broke up whatever
that means i keep hearing they're going
to break them up i don't know exactly
what that looks like um but
to break them up remove the the
liability protection and make them
accountable either they're a publisher
or they're a platform you have to choose
one yeah are you worried about obviously
we've talked about this a lot but are
you worried that if you remove 230 that
in essence they lose the protections and
then they're just going to crack down on
speech more because they're going to be
live
and then they're going to be like all
right we got to get rid of everything
that that is absolutely a worry and
that's why you haven't seen just a
blanket removal of of section 230. um i
think that's why you didn't see
president trump um do away with section
230 because
there there are details like this that
we need to look into but i'm really
grateful um that we have the jim jordans
of the world that are looking into this
um judiciary that that entire committee
there are brilliant minds serving there
and they just need the numbers to be
able to get their agenda passed um they
need to be able to get that out there
because right now everything is party
lines um i mean even something as simple
as is removing a 200 million dollar
earmark for the presidio in nancy
pelosi's district you know that's
straight down party lines democrat says
no no she's the speaker she deserves a
little extra she should get a little
extra ice cream in here right yeah her
twin z fridge and all that stuff um
do you ever think when you're at some of
these hearings like at this point when i
watch especially the big tech hearings i
watch them and jim jordan does do a
great job and i've talked to him about
it but when i watch these hearings it
sort of feels like we're just watching a
movie that we've all seen before yes
zuckerberg will say some nice things and
some things we disagree with the
whistleblower you know this
whistleblower who really is a lefty
activist will sort of say some nice
things but then also became like a
policy advocate for government
intervention but it's just like there's
a lot of talk it's a lot of talk it's
sort of interesting at some level and
then it's kind of like ah nothing ever
really matters because
the next day starts and there we go
right because the democrats won't allow
any progress to be made
and they are in the majority
we congress is a majority
um rule body we are a self-governing
majority rule body so congress makes its
own rules for what happens in in those
chambers in those committee hearings and
the majority has the final say
you know you have you have leader
mccarthy who has offered up privileged
resolutions to remove someone who can't
get a civilian security clearance um
from the intel committee uh eric
swalwell and and but he's allowed to
have
this security clearance in congress on
the intel committee and they won't even
hear it they table the motion they say
no no we're not even discussing this if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell